um uh explain to me uh well first of all
kudos to you K flock and Dougie B for
um being uh man enough to kind of put
issues aside before things get out of
hand and get you know guys I thought
that was a dope thing to see because a
lot of artists we don't see people
squashing beef we see somebody on you
know especially in New York people are
losing their lives left and right man so
I thought that was a amazing considering
you guys are all from the Bronx and uh I
feel like the Bronx
in the drill scene is is not as you know
uh big as Guys from Brooklyn I mean you
guys are kind of like you know waving
that flag and and to be on as a united
front I think that's important um what
was behind you guys you know burying the
hatchet and squashing the beef
I feel like
sometimes like this would be
miscommunication yeah most of the time
most of the time like miscommunication
like
I met people in person like for me like
when I met Dougie B we talked in person
for me so it's like those type of vows
you got to see because a lot of times it
would be the internet you got the
internet in between people and always
custom situation like even with like you
go back to like like 50s who probably
mad [ __ ] going on with the blows all
types of [ __ ] but then you meet people
and sit Downs differently for me so I
feel like I sit down with certain people
and see the bigger picture you heard so
you guys just kind of sat down and were
like hey what are we doing like not yeah
like for me even even with my Miss Bo
guys you know he said collaborable
competition like that's a quote that I'm
always gonna
I feel like that's gonna stand that's me
because it's like at the end of the day
when you compete with people it's never
gonna last because when you collab with
them you can make science yeah let's get
some more there's more money in
collabing than there is in beefing yeah
and that's why I feel like I could be
the artist to do that too because it's
like I don't have to be for anybody like
I don't make diss tracks I don't make
the type of music where people feel like
I gotta choose a sign so when I bring
all these people together it's gonna
make sense yeah I do think that like you
do stand out in that um way amongst your
peers who make drill music is as to
where a lot of your music subject matter
isn't necessarily
uh derived in killing [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying it's like and it's
like you put me in in Greener like my
music is still gonna make people
adrenaline right of course of course you
got so much energy yeah you can't help
it yeah you can still go crazy to my
music but it's not necessarily to the
point where you gotta for me go out the
window for that you know you can still
get crazy